le commandant massoud ne scrute fera
plus les montagnes du pet shop cette
région du nord-est de l'afghanistan
était devenu son fief
c'est là qu'il s'était repliée depuis la
prise de kaboul par les talibans les
étudiants en théologie en 1996 mais
avant de
l'assaut avait été donné au delà des
stands à l'envahisseur soviétique la
guerre qui avait duré près d'un million
de morts en 1992 il en traite en
triomphateur nankin l'ombre au ministre
de la défense il avait abandonné la peau
du sud pour reprendre les armes
ces échanges la capitale construite
entre factions armées afghanes qui
tentait de ça
en 1996 on a des chastes et laissant
derrière eux une ville dé réussira
pourtant regroupent autour de lui
quelques chefs de guerre et incarner au
mieux qu'au mois d'avril est encore de
l'europe à la longue à es6 tarbes à
paris et par le marabout sans avoir
obtenu un réel soutien